third person is under arrest in
connection with the death of Ahmad our
Barry William Bryan junior who recorded
video of our Barry being chased shot and
killed in a Georgia neighborhood back in
February is now charged with murder and
criminal attempt to commit false
imprisonment a father and son are
already charged with murder
Omar Villafranca has been following this
story for us Ahmad our burries father
Marcus and his attorney Ben Crum say
they are encouraged by the arrest of
William rowdy Bryan the man who recorded
the cell phone video of armories death
you can look at the video for yourself
and see that the evidence fits the
crimes that he had been charged with
Kevin Goff is the attorney for Bryan he
has not spoken to the media since his
clients arrest but held a press
conference earlier this week Mr Bryan
has committed no crime and bears no
criminal responsibility in the death of
Ahmad our burring Travis and Gregory
McMichael were arrested and charged with
murder and aggravated assault
in the February 23rd confrontation they
both claimed self-defense according to
the police report on the day of the
shooting
our burry was spotted walking around an
open construction site and the
McMichaels pursued him in a pickup truck
Bryan's attorney says when they passed
his home Bryan got in his own vehicle
and followed in an effort to check out
the commotion he was unarmed at the time
of the shooting and he was not in
communication with Gregory or Travis
McMichael or anyone else during that
timeframe but according to the police
report Gregory McMichael told police
rowdy attempted to block him which was
unsuccessful it is very clear to a mas
family that he was always part of this
lynch mob that executed their child in
broad daylight I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't scared earlier this month in an
interview with our Jacksonville Florida
affiliate wjx Bryan maintained his
innocence truthfully need to be cleared
of this
because I had nothing to do with it the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation will
hold a press conference later on this
morning to talk about Brian's charges
Travis and Gregory McMichael are still
in the Glynn County Jail without bond
Anthony all right Omar thank you